get another branch and
we defeated it
[Music]
anytime Nintendo decides to finally show
off new Zelda stuff is a good day for
any content creator lore detective or
artist out there and when it comes to
the highly anticipated tears of the
Kingdom I continue to be amazed by the
insane work ethic of the Zelda community
in just a few days people have been able
to find the most obscure details
locations were cross-referenced icons
and artwork created or recreated maps
have been compiled by stitching together
parts of the mini-map which others then
use and combined with the XYZ
coordinates on display to retrace every
step our Numa took during the
presentation seriously I'm convinced
that if Zelda fans were alive back in
1888 the Jack the Ripper case would have
been solved in a day anyway by the time
this video goes up there will be a
plethora of extensive analysis videos
out there or being worked on as we speak
so when it comes to analyzing the
presentation as a whole I don't feel
like I can bring a whole lot of new
stuff to the table at this point and I
would just be repeating a lot of the
same information so instead I wanted to
focus on something specific something I
can potentially Give A New Perspective
on but is also significant off in my
eyes to devote an entire video to it
took me a while but as you probably saw
from the thumbnail I found it the green
vials link carries around on his hip
which are seen in various footage and in
some of the official artwork a quick
side note I'm going to be referring to
them as vials throughout the video but
do keep in mind that we don't actually
know what this device is or what it's
called in game it's a placeholder name
which is mostly based on appearance as
well as an early concept for the shika
slate which was supposed to be powered
by vials or syringes containing ancient
energy an idea that was dropped later in
development even after the recent
gameplay demonstration the purpose of
this device is still shrouded in mystery
producer agio Numa never refers to it
during gameplay and because it's quite a
small detail on Link's character model
we don't see much of it in general I've
been dying to find out what these vials
do ever since they first showed up and
with the new gameplay footage in mind I
think I have a pretty good idea now
there's been quite a few theories about
what this strange Gadget could be and if
and how it'll affect the gameplay two of
which I will discuss briefly before I
give my own take on a matter due to the
location of of the device on Link's body
which is the same exact place he
previously kept the sheikah Slate one of
the more popular theories is that it's
closely connected to Link's new powers
in some way one idea that's been thrown
around a lot is that it's some sort of
magic meter that limits how much link
and uses new abilities and can be
expanded over the course of the game to
increase their duration or potency on
the face of it it does make some sense
after all the sheikah Slate was the
source of Link's abilities in the
previous title and so seeing this new
device in its stead would suggest that
it serves a similar function but on
closer review of the gameplay footage
and some overall critical thought the
idea doesn't hold up very well first of
all it's clear that the bracelet on his
right arm is where he draws his magic
from this time around anytime link uses
one of the abilities it gives off a
green glow so why have two objects on
Link's character model that essentially
serve the same purpose why not just have
something on the bracelet that shows how
much juice you got left secondly at no
point in the footage when link activates
his powers do we see an indication that
their use is finite he can fuse Ascend
or glue things to together to his
heart's content without running out of
magic or energy it seems The Only
Exception is recall which has its own
little UI element that counts down when
an object is moving in Reverse it's
similar to the cooldown timer for some
of the Chica slate runes like stasis for
example and for an ability like this
having an indicator that shows how far
back in time you can go makes perfect
sense but if the powers in general had
limited use you would expect to see a UI
element in addition to the vials because
as mentioned before they are quite small
and only visible when link faces a
certain direction on their own they
would be a pretty inefficient way of
handling a magic meter now some games do
communicate certain information without
the use of UI like the health bar in
Dead Space but here it made sense to do
it this way since you're looking at the
characters back 99 of the time anyway
whereas the vials are barely visible
most of the time it would also undermine
the enjoyment of Tears of the Kingdom
quite a bit if we have to constantly
farm for energy just to make use of
these amazing mechanics yes the Zelda
team did consider something similar for
the Chica slate but it was probably
scrapped for a very season I think they
realized that it would be quite tedious
if the player had to constantly monitor
the Slate's battery so implementing it
now in the sequel would likely feel like
a step back the second theory is that
the vials are related to the story
progression in some way many Zelda games
feature some sort of key collectible
often obtained by completing dungeons be
it medallions elements instruments
anything goes really and in some cases
these objects will be used to upgrade
certain aspects of Link's Arsenal or
power like the four elements in the
Minish Cap which increase the power and
capabilities of the pcori blade seeing
as the master sword has been severely
damaged it's likely that there will be
something in the game that is used to
repair or maybe even enhance the sword
perhaps the seven or black objects seen
on the mural in the case of this Theory
I think there are merits to the idea
that the vile share a connection to the
master sword however if this is the case
I think it's only a partial aspect to
them and they actually have a much wider
implication than that I'll get into more
detail about this at the end of the
video but for now let's get into what I
think the vials are and what they do I
suspect that this device is specifically
connected to the new zonite technology
like the parts used to build Vehicles my
guess is that these Contraptions like
the fans for example don't have a power
source of their own in order to operate
they need to tap into an external power
source which is exactly what I think the
vials are basically a portable battery
that can transfer energy wirelessly
you'll notice that when link activates
this fan a battery icon shows up to
indicate how long it can keep spinning
and this icon is tied to link not the
fan itself my guess is that there's a
certain radius from which this
technology can connect to the device on
Link's hip in order to draw power from
it and when link gets too far away from
it it loses connection and stops working
additionally the gadget will be able to
connect to multiple pieces of zonitech
at the same time as long as they are
within this radius which judging from
the footage is quite lenient they can
tap into this device and the more parts
are active at once the faster the
battery will be depleted we can see an
example of this when link activates the
four fans on this wooden raft notice how
the battery drains much faster here
compared to on the boat we see earlier
which only uses 2 fans I also think the
orientation of the propellers may play a
role in how fast the battery runs out of
juice obviously pushing something
forward requires a lot less energy than
lifting something off the ground it
seems that regardless of the amount of
fans that are spinning there's always
only one battery icon present which
makes perfect sense if they all draw
energy from a single power source I.E
the fans are not the ones running out of
energy the device on Link's hip is if my
assumptions are correct this setup will
automatically solve a couple of issues
for example say link falls off this
flying machine if the fans had their own
power source the vehicle would likely
continue to move without him for as long
as their batteries last but if they rely
on a connection with the vials they will
stop working as soon as link falls down
far enough away from them which prevents
this flying machine from going on its
own Journey it also puts a limit on how
far you'll be able to travel with these
vehicles depending on how far along you
are in the story or how much you've
explored Hyrule which also ties into the
possibilities for upgrading this device
one visual detail that could prove a
connection between the zone and the
vials is that if you look closely you
can see that each individual vial is
made up of three segments and the
battery icon has three bars as opposed
to just one single bar in most of the
footage we've seen as well as in the
official artwork link is in possession
of four vials however in the gameplay
demonstration he only has one which
makes sense because it's clear that the
gameplay shown takes place in the early
game right after the tutorial section
has been completed for me this also
rules out the idea that each vial
represents one of Link's Powers which
has been suggested in the past but
obviously this doesn't match after all
he only has one vial here and yet he has
access to four abilities I suspect that
when we first obtain this device it'll
come with either one vial already
installed or the first via was collected
on the tutorial Island we do see a
battery icon on the minimap if I had to
guess this could be an upgrade station
where you can exchange one or more
Collectibles for a new vial or maybe
just a third of one and the more you
have the longer you'll be able to power
these vehicles they will no doubt place
a heavy restriction on this in the early
game to prevent the player from being
able to reach every Island right from
the get-go if not it would completely
nullify every other method used to reach
the islands like recall for example and
the footage does seem to reflect this
restriction the speed at which the
battery depletes when this raft takes to
the sky clearly shows that it's not
gonna get more than a few feet off the
ground not exactly a viable option to
reach new heights but as stated before
the more vials are added to Link's new
Gadget the greater the distances he'll
be able to Traverse and the more pieces
of tech he'll be able to power at the
same time providing the option to build
more elaborate vehicles in the future in
the case of the car we can even see an
object in the back that looks like a
bigger version of the vials and I'm
quite confident that it's based on the
same concept apparently at some point we
can attach an extra power source in
addition to the vials to get even more
out of these vehicles the car consists
of quite a few different parts like a
steering wheel two headlights and at
least two wheels maybe even four if it's
a four-wheel drive all of which will
likely take up their own share of
battery power judging by how fast one
vial drains when using four fans I can
imagine that this car probably wouldn't
get very far on just the vials alone so
the option for an extra battery is no
doubt crucial for more complicated
Vehicles like this one as for what we
need to collect in order to upgrade this
gadget we of course don't know but I'd
wager it has to be something that's rare
something scarce that can only be
obtained in very specific places or from
unique enemies or bosses as a quick
example this giant robot boss which has
one Cube on its body that's different
from the others or maybe vials can be
added in exchange for multiple
Collectibles like the zonai charges or
other parts like it which would be
similar to how Robbie created chica
weapons and armor for Link in the
previous game alternatively the vials
could be connected to the hypothetical
tears or orbs we collect at the end of
equally hypothetical dungeons who knows
which brings us to the last point if the
device unlink's hip connects the various
zonai Tech this could mean that it's not
just limited to Vehicles alone we've
seen other zonai artifacts that also
seem to work on the same principle like
the flamethrower or this Canon stick
that shoots explosives these two will
most likely have limit added use or else
they would be extremely op so when link
activates the flamethrower for example
it's possible that it will drain the
vials in the same way the vehicles do
the footage shows that the battery does
charge back up again on its own once the
fan is deactivated so if the zonai
weapons operate on the same Principle as
the vehicles this would provide an
effective cooldown on these weapons
where you have to wait for the battery
to charge back up again it may even
punish you with an extended cooldown if
you let it drain all the way similar to
the stamina meter and as you upgrade
your vials these types of weapons become
increasingly more viable in combat
speaking of combat the same thing May
apply to the master sword as well this
is highly speculative and I could
definitely say that the master sword
will work on a completely different
principle but let's say that as opposed
to being reforged with steel the broken
parts of the sword will instead be
restored or partially replaced by zonai
technology after all in the game's logo
we do see that half of the sword has
been replaced by some sort of green
energy if this is the same energy that
powers the vehicles and other zonai Tech
it's possible that this new version of
the master sword also draws energy from
the vials meaning that similar to breath
of the wild the master sword can run out
of juice once again I know some found
the limited use of the massasaur
disappointing but it was obviously done
to prevent every other weapon from being
made obsolete by the Legendary Blade it
was a necessary trade-off and I'm sure
it all works similar in this game
especially since the new fuse ability is
such a cool addition that isn't to say
that the sword won't become an infinite
weapon later on but if it does it will
likely be close to the end of the game
anyway I think that does it for now I'm
not too sure how many videos I'm going
to be putting out about the gameplay
demo because honestly I think a lot of
it speaks for itself and was explained
pretty well by onnuma himself of course
if I manage to catch something
significant in the background or
something like that I'll look into the
possibilities for more videos but I
don't intend on milking this
presentation for every little detail if
you want to catch some of my stray
thoughts and small discoveries you can
keep an eye on my Twitter as always I
will save any patreon and member shout
outs for the bigger stuff so for those
of you who joined after my recent video
about the Triforce just hang on a little
longer that is all for now and I hope to
see you all next time
[Music]
foreign